[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to once again this is the
fifth time i'm saying that now be
discussing the events that transpired in
the harry potter universe after the
books and films ended i have now made
four separate videos on this topic to
date parts one two three and four which
each cover ten separate characters and
what they got up to post deathly hallows
between those four videos i've managed
to cover
voldemort neville hermione ron harry
george luna hagrid draco the dursleys
umbridge fudge lockhart flitwick filch
ollivander kingsley shacklebolt pomona
sprout arthur molly weasley percy
weasley aberforth dumbledore fleur
seamus finnegan mcgonagall narcissa
lucius cormac mclagan group rita skeeter
slughorn dean thomas
charlie weasley sybil trolone forensic
oliver wood madame maxime bill weasley
pansy parkinson aunt marge patil twins
and ginny weasley today i'm going to be
continuing that trend and giving you
part 5 and don't worry there will be a
part 6 of what happened to these 10
characters after the war i'll link parts
1 2 3 and 4 in the pinned comment
without further ado let's dive into the
lives of 10 characters post-war and post
deathly hallows
1. newt's commander i know what you're
thinking newt scamander isn't he from
the fantastic beast films he isn't in
harry potter and if you thought that
well you'd only be sort of right sure
enough we don't see newt scamander's
face in the harry potter films but that
certainly doesn't mean that he's absent
from the harry potter universe newt is a
famous magi zoologist and the author of
fantastic beasts and where to find them
an approved book at hogwarts school so
you can bet that he's kicking around
somewhere to add to this there's
actually a newt easter egg in the harry
potter films where he appears on the
marauders map if you want to know the
explanation for his presence there well
you're going to have to watch my video
on it anyway despite what some sources
may say
newt was very much alive after the
deathly hallows book film timeline had
ended by the time the 1990s rolled
around newt was pseudo retired and
living in dorset with tina and their
three pet nasals hoppy milly and mauler
i say pseudo retired because newt a
workaholic continued several projects
including studying fire slugs and
authoring a book entitled a children's
anthology of monsters newt eventually
went on to become a great grandfather
when his grandson rolfe married luna
lovegood and had two children lorkhan
and lysander
2. cho chang cho chang was a half blood
witch born in 1978 who attended hogwarts
from 1990 to 1997
where she was sorted into ravenclaw
house
joe was polite well
and easy to get along with and cho is
well known for her relationships with
several male figures in the series
including cedric diggory and even harry
potter himself
after the death of cedric cho was never
quite the same and as it turns out she
ended up marrying a muggle upon
graduation
perhaps this was just her way of
escaping the madness of the wizarding
world particularly after a lethal
wizarding war there are some theories
circling around the internet that cho
actually ended up marrying dudley
dursley of all people but if you want to
learn more about that whole situation
then watch my video on it three
andromeda tonks andromeda tonks born
andromeda black of the house of black
was an english witch that married
muggleborn ted tonks together her and
ted had a daughter named fedora who we
know as a respected aura and member of
the order of the phoenix
andromeda despite being a member of the
house of black was not an evil witch so
it should come as no surprise that she
was disowned by her family a group of
pureblood supremacists after she married
a muggleborn andromeda was also a good
example of a southern student that
wasn't and didn't turn bad
tragically many of andromeda's family
members died during the events of the
deathly hallows including her husband
ted and her daughter in fedora with
nymphadora leaving behind a son teddy
who she had with her husband remus lupin
andromeda was left to take care of him
4. moaning myrtle myrtle warren aka
moaning myrtle was a muggle-born witch
born in either 1928 or 1929.
myrtle attended hogwarts from 1940 to
1943
some of the same years as voldemort and
was eventually killed in 1943 by
slytherin's basilisk under tom riddle's
orders
after the incident she became a ghost
who haunted the second floor girl's
bathroom
despite being well dead myrtle became
quite a prominent character in the harry
potter series
known for her strange interactions with
harry the last time harry saw myrtle
however was when she was ordered to
leave the bathroom by severus snape
though there is nothing in harry potter
canon indicating what happened to myrtle
it's worth mentioning that she does
appear in the cursed child where she can
be found still haunting the bathroom
5. xenophilius lovegood
xenophilius was the husband of late
pandora lovegood and father to fan
favorite luna lovegood
xenophilius was also notably the creator
of the quibbler magazine
during the second wizarding war luna was
captured by the death eaters which
prompted a desperate xenophilius to
alert death eaters during a visit from
harry potter in the hopes that they
would release luna after henry ron and
hermione escaped his home xenophilius
was promptly arrested and sent to
azkaban he was finally released after
voldemort's defeat on the 2nd of may
1998.
not much is known of what happened to
xenophilius after that
but it's likely that he continued on
with the quibbler and occasionally took
care of his grandsons
6. katie bell katie bell was a british
half-blood witch born in the year 1979
she was a member of gryffindor house and
represented the house on the quidditch
pitch taking on the role of chaser she
was a year above harry and we see her
name mentioned here and there throughout
the franchise however her character was
never really brought to the forefront of
our attention until the half-blood
prince when while on a trip to hogsmeade
katie suffered a brutal attack from an
unidentified curse
because it took katie six months to
recover she ended up returning to
hogwarts in 1997 to 1998 to repeat her
seventh year katie along with others
fought valiantly in the battle of
hogwarts and was seen sitting after the
battle with cho padma and leanne no one
knows what happened to katie after that
7. bane
bane was a centaur who lived in the
forbidden forest central colony along
with forensic
though the centaurs did not initially
join the battle of hogwarts they were
later shamed into it after hagrid called
bane a coward not much is known of what
happened to bane but we do know he
survived the battle bane also appears in
the cursed child act 2 scene 5 when
harry potter is looking for his son
albus 8. winky winky was a fan favorite
character that was omitted from the
films entirely a female house elf that
served the crouch family for many years
and later worked at hogwarts
at one stage in winky's life she fell
into a depression after she felt that
she had failed to service barty crouch
which resulted in a drinking problem her
addiction to butterbeer was a problem
for many years
led by creature winky did end up helping
to fight against the death eaters during
the battle of hogwarts alongside other
house elves after the war had ended
winky continued to work at hogwarts and
fortunately ended up beating her
butterbeer addiction 9. poppy pomfrey
poppy pomfrey also known as madame
pomfrey was the matron at hogwarts
school of witchcraft and wizardry
responsible for taking care of the
students and staff of the school however
as it turns out pomfrey wasn't just
responsible for healing people as she
fought valiantly alongside her students
and co-workers in the battle of hogwarts
taking down at least one death eater
herself
after the battle we can only assume that
madame pomfrey returned to her regular
post tending to the various medical
maladies that came through the doors of
the hogwarts hospital wing if you want
to go by cursed child cannon then we do
actually know for certain that she was
still working at the school in 2020
10. mundungus fletcher mandungus
fletcher was a half-bud wizard with a
rich history of criminal activity
there aren't many positive ways to
describe mandungus as a person as
throughout the story he always seemed to
be getting into trouble and getting on
people's bad sides
mandungus is even partly responsible for
the death of moody as he abandoned him
during the battle of the seven potters
he also shamelessly raids number 12
grimmeld place
looting and selling all of the valuables
that lay within
after being confronted by harry for this
he disappeared and went into hiding
that is until he was imprisoned in
azkaban for impersonating ninfurious
it's unlikely that mundungus played any
part in the battle of hogwarts and it's
likely that he simply returned to his
life as a questionable and unauthorized
dealer of magical artifacts and that's
it for this video i've got 16 more
characters to cover in this series noted
down but there may still be some that
i've missed if you want to request a
particular character then leave a
comment down below links to part 1 2 3
and 4 are in the pinned comment
if you want to support the channel then
please like the video and subscribe
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
[Music]
you